Greetings friends. Uh once again welcome
to our program I like to know. We are
very happy to be here with you again. I
am in the company of pastor Steven Bour
the president and main speaker of this
ministry uh secrets unsealed sumptv. Uh,
Pastor Boore, again, what a privilege it
is to be here with you.
>> You know, I am very thankful that you're
willing to help us here at Secrets
Unsealed. It's a real blessing to the
ministry.
>> Amen. Thank you. Thank you for inviting
me. And I am uh Daniel Miranda, pastor
of the Oroscei and Sanger Bilingual
Seventh Day Adventist Churches and I am
very pleased to be here in this studio
as well on this program. Uh before we
begin, I would like to remind you all
that if you want to send questions that
you want to be answered in this program,
there is an email address where you can
send them. The email address is
tbsumptv.org.
Again, that's tvsumtv.org.
There is a team that goes over the
questions and they select the questions
that will be aired. So, uh, make sure
that your question is is really good and
of the general interest to the public so
that it gets picked. Uh, before we
begin, uh, Pastor Bor, if you could lead
us in prayer.
>> Let's pray.
Father in heaven, uh, now as we begin
this program, we plead for the presence
of the Holy Spirit.
>> Amen.
>> Give us clarity of thought.
Give us words to speak.
>> Amen. And we're thankful, Lord, for all
of the individuals that send us
questions. I know that these questions
are close to their hearts. We ask that
you will bless us as we attempt to
answer these questions and that you will
bless those who are watching this
program that it might be a blessing to
them as well. We pray in Jesus name.
Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Well, here is a question that is coming
from South Sudan. Pastor South Sudan.
>> Wow.
>> Mapul Malat. Now I believe you're the
expert on the trumpets. So I will let
you do most of the talking. This
question um is on Revelation 9. What is
the meaning of Revelation
9? You know Revelation 9, we have the
fifth and sixth trumpets
and there is uh there is there are many
views in the Adventist church regarding
the trumpets. But I think there are some
principles regardless of the view that
everyone every person holds. there are
some principles that the biblical
interpreters in our church follow that
we should we can agree on and and let's
talk about that for a moment pastor
bore.
>> Okay. The the first item which I feel is
not negotiable when it comes to
interpreting the trumpets is that we
need to interpret them in a historicist
mode.
>> Amen.
Uh you know we say the churches the
seven churches which were literal
churches in Asia
>> represent periods of church history one
right after the other culminating at the
end.
>> Yeah.
>> From apostolic times the time when the
prophet wrote till the end of time.
>> We say the same about the seals. The
seals begin to be fulfilled in the days
in which the pro prophet John wrote and
they fulfill step after step reaching
their climax at the coming of Christ.
The same is true of the trumpets. And
why do I emphasize this point that we
need to interpret the trumpets from a
historicist perspective?
>> It's because we have individuals in the
church who are projecting all of the
trumpets to the future.
>> That's right.
>> In other words, none of them have been
fulfilled yet.
and uh
>> or a double application
>> or or double application. Yes. Uh now
there's no doubt whatsoever that for
example the sixth trumpet
uh is describing
uh events that happen around the year
because we know that because Revelation
chapter 10
is in the context of the sixth trumpet.
In Revelation chapter 10, Ellen White
uniformly tells us that Revelation 10 is
talking about the Millerite movement in
1844.
>> And the and time will be no longer
prophetic time because 1844 is the last
time prophecy of the Bible. So she makes
it very clear that revelation 10 which
is a parenthesis in the sixth trumpet
applies to the Millerite movement which
means that that in its primary
application
the application is not future. The
application already took place in the
past
>> and we know that the seventh trumpet is
when the father and Jesus take over the
kingdoms of the world. That's the
climax. Mhm.
>> Now, uh there are different
interpretations as to the sequence of
the trumpets, the fulfillment,
historical fulfillment.
For example, Sevin Maxwell, who was my
uh church history teacher in the
seminary. When I went to the seminary,
he believed that the first trumpet
represents the destruction of Jerusalem
by the Romans. However, Uriah Smith
believed that that that the first
trumpet deals with the fall of the Roman
Empire.
>> So, uh there are variations as to the
events that are being described in the
trumpets.
Uh but most everyone until recently
believed that the trumpets were future
uh were not future that the trumpets
took place uh in the course of history.
And of course, the seventh trumpet has
not transpired yet. Um what does this
tell us? Well, I think what it tells us
is that uh there will be variations of
interpretation of details. Yeah.
>> In the trumpets, although we all agree
on the general parameters of the
fulfillment of the trumpets.
>> That's correct.
>> For example, the fifth trumpet uh is
interpreted by Ranco Stefanovich
uh who uh I don't know if he still
teaches at the Andrew Seminary. uh he
understands the fifth trumpet to
represent uh um the French revolution.
>> Uh I agree with that position by the
way. Um but but there are those who say
no no it represents the you know the
Muslim invasions and so on into the
west. Um there are variations in other
words in interpretation of specific
details within the trumpets
>> but uh but the general tenor is that
they are to be understood from a
historicist perspective and they are not
uh future.
>> Yes.
>> But they were fulfilled in the past and
they're in the process of being
fulfilled.
>> Very good. Very good. And I would agree
with that. The time in this program
doesn't allow us to go over every
detail. that chapter is packed with
symbolism
uh and it'll require a lot of time but I
know you have a series that you recorded
and also some material
>> that perhaps you can refer to our
audience so that if they're interested
in your position
um they can go to your material and
study it. you know, for many years, uh,
they there was this, uh, Revelation
seminar that was produced, uh, in Texas,
uh, 24 lessons, uh, going chapter by
chapter in Revelation. Whenever I got to
lesson number 23, which was on the
trumpets, I skipped it [laughter]
because because really I I did not uh
really uh understand
uh or agree with Uriah Smith's
interpretation of the trumpets. Uh you
know, he takes three of the trumpets
just to describe the barbarian
invasions. Now, are the barbarian
invasions so important that you need
three trumpets from basically one
century uh to to explain that? And I had
issues, you know, with the fifth and
sixth trumpet, the demons that come from
the abyss and so on, which is a vivid
description of what happened at the
French Revolution. Ellen White called it
a new manifestation of satanic power.
>> Yeah.
uh and and so uh I would skip that
lesson. But then uh when I was at Fresno
Central Church uh pastoring, I decided
that in prayer meeting we would study
the book of Revelation from beginning to
end.
>> And when I got to the trumpets, I can't
skip the trumpets. And so I sat down and
said, I am going to study the trumpets
for myself.
>> In other words, I'm not going to go into
what other people have said. I'm going
to apply the principle of interpreting
the symbols, looking at the context,
looking at what comes before, what comes
after, and so on, applying uh sound
biblical principles. And the result was
uh this uh study note that we did at an
anchor school of theology on the seven
trumpets.
uh using the principles the uh
grammatical historical principles that
we use at 7th day avenous uh I developed
this uh study notes for the anchor
school of theology.
>> Very good.
>> And so I would encourage uh those who
are watching the program if you really
want to know a lot more about uh those
uh bizarre aspects of the trumpets uh
trumpet number five and trumpet number
six. Uh I think that there's a good
explanation in these study notes.
>> Very good. Make sure you download the
material. I believe they can download it
for free as well, right?
>> Uh I think I think it's available for
download. If they download the app,
>> okay,
>> they should be able to get it for free.
>> Very good. Thank you, Pastor Boore. Very
good. We're going to go to the next
question. This question is from coming
from Cherry. We don't know the place
where she's writing from. Uh another
question on the book of Revelation. I'm
really enjoying these questions. It says
in Revelation 17:12, it says, "The 10
horns which you saw are the 10 kings who
have received no kingdom as yet, but
they receive authority for one hour as
kings with the beast."
This is the question here after quoting
this verse. Is this an actual time
prophecy?
I guess she's referring to the one hour.
or could it be similar to for a short
time type of prophecy? Thank you for
your help. So the question is
specifically not on the 10 horns but
it's on the hour where it says that
expression one hour.
>> I personally believe this is just an
expression that is a reference to for a
short time. Mhm.
>> Actually the same the same chapter uh
she quoted Revelation 7 um verse verse
12.
Um but then when we read verse 10,
notice what verse 10
>> says. There are also seven kings.
>> Five have fallen. One is and the other
has not yet come.
>> And when he comes,
this is the seventh head or the seventh
king. He must continue a short time. You
know, there's a parallel between the
seventh head and these 10 horns,
>> right?
>> Um I believe the 10 horns are on the
seven head which is the future the
future political power that will arise
uh in the last days. So [snorts] ver
verse 10 says for a short time but verse
12 it uses the expression 1 hour. So if
we take the context 1 hour is a short
time. Same thing happens in revelation
18 when it talks about the destruction
of of Babylon
>> and the fall of Babylon. It says for for
a short it uses the expression one hour
but then it uses the expression also for
a short uh time. It says her judgments
have come in one hour in verse 10 for in
one hour your judgment has come. But
when you keep reading you know that this
actually means suddenly quickly her
destruction came.
>> Uhhuh. Uh you know the the writer
I did didn't notice I didn't use the
word author. Mhm.
>> The writer of the book of revelation was
the apostle John.
>> Yes.
>> So what we need to do is maybe go to the
gospel of John also to see what the word
ha or hour means in Greek. So let's go
to the gospel of John.
>> Okay.
>> Uh I agree with you 100% that it refers
to a short but indefinite period of
time.
>> Uh in John chapter 2 and verseh 4. Uh
very interesting verse. It's the the
wedding uh of Kaa.
And uh Jesus says to her, "Woman, what
does your concern have to do with me? My
hour has not yet come."
>> Yes.
>> What did Jesus mean by hour? Is he
talking about uh 60 minutes? No, of
course not. He's talking about his final
passion,
>> right? Um also John chapter 4 in the
experience with the Samaritan woman
chapter 4 and verse 21 and verse 23 uh
Jesus said to her woman believe me the
hour is coming it means the time is
coming
>> right
>> the hour is coming when you will neither
on this mountain nor in Jerusalem
worship the father doesn't mean that
they're going to worship the father for
one hour
>> right
>> and then verse 23 says but the hour is
coming and now is when the true
worshippers will worship the father in
spirit and truth.
>> Right.
>> And then you have uh John 12. Uh
remember this is the same writer of the
book of revelation.
>> Very common Johannine expression.
>> Absolutely. Uh chapter 12 verse 23. Uh
Jesus says uh but Jesus answered them
saying the hour has come that the son of
man should be glorified. Talking about
his passion. Now will the dispassion
last for 60 minutes? Of course not.
>> It the moment has arrived. In other
words, indefinite,
>> right?
>> But the moment has come. And verse 27
also says, "Now my soul is troubled and
what shall I say? Father save me from
this hour, but for this purpose I came
to this hour, which is the entire period
of his passion."
>> And uh you know, let's uh take a couple
of examples. I have more from the gospel
of John. It's a very common expression
in John. Uh, Revelation chapter 3 and
verse 10
um is an interesting verse.
Uh, Revelation chapter 3 and verse 10.
You want to read that?
>> Yeah, sure. Revelation 3:10 says,
"Because you have kept my command to
persevere,
I will also keep you from the hour of
trial, which shall come upon the whole
world to test those who dwell on the
earth."
So, let me ask you, did this trial uh of
uh the church of um I think uh what
church?
>> Philadelphia. Philadelphia.
>> Of Philadelphia. Uh did their trial last
only for 60 minutes?
>> No,
>> of course not. The entire Millerite
movement, which it points to.
>> Uh we also have Revelation 14:7, the
hour of his judgment has come. So, the
judgment only lasts 60 minutes.
>> Of course not.
>> Of course not. And then there are the
references in Revelation 18 that you
made mention to. So, so the word hour
here signifies a period of time whose
specific limits are not mentioned.
>> Yes. Excellent. I think that well covers
our question. I I hope that our dear
sister [clears throat] Cherry may may
find some some good input in this in
these answers. Okay. Next question is
coming from Germo.
Um it says, "Hello family at Sam TV. My
question today is about the sixth
commandment, you shall not murder and
its relation to the death of another
human by an act of self-defense."
I have heard about the use of the Hebrew
words and rats
and how they are used to translate kill
and murder. Hence, taking someone's life
in self-defense would not be a sin.
Also, could you comment on what God
meant in Genesis 9:6 where it is said
that God established capital punishment?
Thank you.
>> Okay. So, what do we say about that?
[laughter]
>> We have to understand that
these commands, you know, Genesis, you
know, 96. Well, before we go to the
capital punishment,
uh, you know, the eye for an eye, the
tooth for a tooth, and and the
self-defense principle, we need to
understand that these commands are given
in a in a context of sin, in a specific
context.
the what the commandment
uh you shall not murder what it
prohibits is the taking of someone's
life by violence willful intentional
>> but we know that there are other
provisions for example when you would
take someone's life unintentionally you
know there is exodus 23 I believe it you
know with an axe you're working
>> uh of course for that you know there
were there were provisions that could go
to the city of refuge
and stay there and save their life. And
the provision was not because it was
necessarily accounted to the person of
sin, but because of the avenger, the
goel,
>> right,
>> would uh would persecute them and try to
take vengeance. So there was the
provision of of fleeing to the city of
refuge.
>> But but if it was discovered in the
city, the the person who fled to the
city of refuge had to present himself
before the high priest and an
investigation of the case is done.
>> That's correct. And if the individual is
truly guilty of premeditated murder,
then that individual was was released to
the avenger.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh but but if if it was an accidental
thing, he could remain in the city until
the death of the high priest and then he
could go back home.
>> Exactly. So
>> so we need to go beyond this simply
taking someone's life. Now, uh the death
of someone in itself is already bad.
It's it's tragic. It's tragic. And and
we live in the world of sin when when
accidents unintentional accidents can
happen
>> or or or in cases like self-defense as
is being spoken of here. Um you know
that that that could be that could be uh
justified.
But
you know if I conclude what I'm trying
to say here is that we need to
we need to be very pragmatic in the way
we approach this this text because God
is trying with this to
it's not the ideal context but he's
trying to lessen the evil that it would
result if these laws did not exist
otherwise
>> you know for like the capital punishment
as well. God is trying to preserve life.
I know that it's coming through
destruction and to the death of another
person. But in trying to avoid a a
greater evil, he allows this so that
there could be some regulations.
>> Uh you know maybe I can read a couple of
uh texts here from scripture. Um first
of all on premeditated murder.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh Exodus 21:12. He who strikes a man so
that he dies shall surely be put to
death.
>> Yes.
>> However, if he did not lie in weight,
but God delivered him into his hand,
then I will appoint for you a place
where he may flee. That's the city of
refuge. But if a man acts with
premeditation against his neighbor to
kill him by treachery, you shall take
him from my altar that he may die. In
other words, premeditated murder was uh
was uh that led to the death of the
person who actually committed the act.
>> But if it was accidental, that was a
different story. Uh notice numbers uh
35:22-2.
uh uh if you want to read that numbers
uh 35
22 through 25 where it's uh talking
about the cities of refuge.
>> Yes,
>> maybe you can read that when you get
there.
>> 22 22-2
>> 35 22-2
>> Yes. The Bible says, "But if he pushes
him suddenly without emnity, or throws
anything at him without laying in
weight, or uses a stone by which a man
could die, throwing it at him without
seeing him so that he dies while he was
not his enemy, or seeking his harm, then
the congregation shall judge between the
man's layer and the avenger of blood
according to these judgments." So the
congregation shall deliver the man's
layer from the hand of the avenger of
blood, and the congregation shall return
him to the city of refuge where he had
fled and shall remain there until the
death of the high priest who was
anointed with the holy oil.
>> So So there you have the two scenarios.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Exodus 21, premeditated murder.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh Numbers 35, if if it was an accident.
>> Yes. uh then the individual could find
refuge in the city of refuge after the
investigation of the case if it was an
accidental thing then he could remain in
the city of refuge.
>> Yes.
So I think uh now any any additional
comments before we go to the next
question uh or the time is running out
actually but any additional comments on
on the self-defense that is referred to
>> um you know I don't find anything
directly in the Bible that deals with
self-defense.
Um,
you know, do we have enough faith in the
Lord that the Lord can deliver us
without taking justice into our own
hands? That's a big question.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, and you know, I, for example, I've
never carried a gun.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I'm going to say I'm going to
have a gun in the house in case somebody
comes and I'm going to protect the
family. Uh, you say, "Well, that's kind
of callous. Shouldn't you protect your
family?" Well, the fact is that God can
protect the family. Mhm.
>> Uh so uh you know I I don't find
anything directly in the Bible. Maybe
you you can find something in the Bible
on the issue of self-defense.
>> No, but I think of you know when Peter
tried to you know cut the the the the
ear of the high priest servant when
Jesus if he that kills with the sword
shall be killed with the sword. And um
even though that was not Peter's
self-defense uh per se, but we see that
Jesus try not to defend himself. Now I
do not I do not completely negate the
possibility of that when it is in the
spot of a moment and uh someone is going
to try to take your life or the life of
someone and and you're defending
yourself but uh in that defense you harm
the other person very badly. That can
end
>> his or her life.
uh I think in those situations though we
should not act premeditatively
yet there is the possibility that that
can happen and the verses that we have
just read I think will clear that person
because it was not by intention which I
think is the principle here
premeditation
uh in that case
>> I think I think that that is a good
answer premeditation is the key
>> is the key yes
>> and mainly for vengeance purposes
>> exactly now if we do it for vengeance
Absolutely. The Bible is very clear on
that. We should not avenge of our
enemies. Um, but it's it's a complex
question and we recognize that our
answer perhaps may not have been
satisfactory, but it's it's a good
opportunity to continue studying this.
Well, thank you friends for uh joining
us in this program. Our time is is up
and we will see you in our next program.
Remember to send us your questions. Uh
keep this ministry in prayer. as we
continue to share the word of God with
others. God bless you.